welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and it sucks it
sucks this news that you've probably
just woken up to if you're like me after
endgame you kind of wanted the MCU to
take more risks with their types of
movies you know do something a bit
different
so when Doctor Strange in the multiverse
of madness was announced last year and
with it the tagline that it was going to
be Marvel's first horror movie then
chances are you are over the moon the
horror genre is one of my favorites
even bad horrors I absolutely love it's
a genre that I find the most
exhilarating because it's where you can
see your deepest and darkest fears play
out on the screen and at points it can
be like reliving a nightmare
horror is one of those genres that will
always be popular it was there before
western movies and it'll be around long
after comic book movies die out
obviously hearing that Doctor Strange
would have a horror aesthetic with some
brilliant brilliant news especially
because of the mind-bending visual
effects that Marvel are now able to put
on screen with his success of Joker this
year comic book movie fans are clearly
craving something darker and Marvel look
like they were going to change with the
times and make just one character gets
something to sink their teeth into but
nope seems like they just want to do
more of their cookie cutter kids stuff
before we get into the full story make
sure you subscribe to the channel to
keep up to date with the news on the
movie as I'm sure over the next couple
of months there'll be a lot of big
announcements coming out in regards to
it anyway without the way thank you for
clicking the video now let's get into
the report so Marvel Studios have
confirmed that Scott Derrickson the
director of Doctor Strange will not be
working on a sequel in a statement that
was exclusively given to Variety Marvel
said Marvel Studios and Scott Derrickson
have a mclee parted ways and Doctor
Strange in the multiverse of madness due
to creative differences
we remain grateful to Scott for his
contributions to the MCU derrickson
himself later tweeted Marvel and I have
mutually agreed to part ways on Doctor
Strange in the multiverse of madness due
to creative differences
I'm thankful for our collaboration and
will remain on as EP which is PR Talk
for Marvel wouldn't let me do a 1 or 2
so they fired me EP means executive
producer but it's rare that they
actually get involved in things
Christopher Nolan was an executive
producer on Batman V Superman and Tim
Burton was an executive producer on
Batman Forever but I really don't think
they had anything to do with the film
and it's unlikely that derrickson will
still be involved if he had to step down
honestly this is massively disappointing
news kind of kind of feels like it's
time to bargain with Dormammu again you
know do something different this wasn't
the timeline that we wanted you idiots
it's obviously a huge blow to the
franchise because derrickson was one of
the directors that was involved with the
series that actually seemed like they
were doing something different I think
overall it just shows the ins and outs
of Disney at the moment I remember when
Edgar Wright left ant-man and this was
clearly because he had a lot of ideas
for the movie but Marvel wanted their
film to be a certain way when given
reasons to why step-down Edgar said I
think the most diplomatic answer is I
wanted to make a Marvel movie but I
don't think they really wanted to make
an Edgar Wright movie so it does look
like we will be getting a diluted
version of Doctor Strange - which I will
still seek but obviously it's a shame
because Disney just seemed to hire these
directors and then completely restrict
their creative control we saw this in
the case of JJ Abrams recently with the
rise of Skywalker you haven't seen my JJ
cut video then basically he was hampered
massively by the studio and made to cut
things so the movie ended up being a
complete mess in my opinion I'd only get
too much into it because I've already
covered it but it looks like Disney are
just snapping directors away one by one
the creative director and showrunner of
the Lizzie McGuire reboot has just quit
after two episodes because Disney were
apparently doing things behind the
scenes that they didn't want them to and
it seems like they are really stifling
what can and can't be done at the moment
which is a shame it just seems like we
will forever get a new at MCU unless the
Russo brothers are behind it which is
frustrating as a fan because I want to
see Marvel movies
more creative apparently the movie will
not be delayed and though the search for
a new director is underway the film is
still meant to be meeting its schedule
this means that it will be released on
May 7 2021 and then it will come off the
back of one division personally I think
this news sucks by let me know what you
think in the comment section below if
you enjoyed this video then please give
it a thumbs up and make sure you check
out our breakdown of the JJ Kirkwood
you'll be linked at the end we go over
everything that you need to know about
what was originally supposed to be in
the movie so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more if
you want to come chat to me after the
video then make sure you follow me on
twitter at definition whitey or head
over to my disk or server which would be
linked in the description below we drop
videos on there early so if you want to
see stuff before anyone else and that's
the best place to be it's free to join
and we have an awesome community so
hopefully I see you over there very soon
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thank you for taking the time to watch
this I've been definition you've been
the best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you